ています
[音楽]
[拍手]
駄文
[音楽]
ああああああme
おはようございます
物理学の研究をしている絵のと輝明です
これから皆さんと一緒に
た沢山塩酢の未来について一緒に考えてみ
たいと思います
早速いですが
この写真ご存知でしょうか
これは半世紀ほど前にアポロ計画の中で月
に入った宇宙飛行士が地球を撮影した
アースライズ地球のでと呼ばれる写真です
漆黒の宇宙の中に良い玉の上青く輝く地球
が出ているこの写真は史上最も影響力を
持った写真の一つともいわれるいいます
この写真に代表されるように20世紀から
の科学と技術の発展によって私たちは月に
1を送り込み
巨大な加速器を作り宇宙の深淵を覗き込む
ような望遠鏡を手にすることができました
しかし私たちの生活の隅々まで科学と技術
が浸透している位4で最先端の科学研究家
そのせいか活動については私たち
普通の人にとっては非常に遠く離れたもの
になっていわば魔法や神話のようになって
しまっているんじゃないかという心配も
あります
こういった懸念に対して応えることが
できるかもしれない
最近話題になっているキーワードの1つに
シチズンさんエンストいうのがあります
私は縁があって日本の金沢で不思議な雷雲
を探す雷雲プロジェクトというのをやって
います
日本でも昔から社会問題の解決などで市民
価格というのはありました
しかし最近使われているこの英語の湿潤
さんエンストいうのはインターネットが
発展した中でウェブサイトを通じて最先端
の科学研究の一翼を市民科学者が担って
いくというそういういう活動です
初期の頃の代表的な例の一つに
ギャラクシーズ
いうのがありました
このギャラクシーずーーというのは大量に
撮影された銀河の天体画像を市民科学者が
家は決して分類していくというそういう
プロジェクトでした大学院生の研究者だけ
だと全然時間が足りなかったのが一瞬で
終わってしかもその方の交流からいろんな
新しい科学的な発見があった事例として
着目されてい
これに触発されてずにバースト呼ばれる
英語のサイトが立ち上がり多くの室前3 s
のプロジェクトがそこで行われるように
なっています
私はこれを国内でもできないかなと思って
いてそれを始めるようになったストーリー
を少し紹介したいと思います
私はもともとして寸サイズの研究をしてい
たわけではありませんもともとですね宇宙
物理学の研究をしていましたこれは
ブラックホールが周りのものを飲み込んで
いくそういう cg になっていて
こののみ込まれていく物質がで非常に高温
になって x 線やガンマ線と呼ばれる目
には見えないとてもエネルギーの高い光を
出します
こういった光は地球まで届いていてしかし
地球の大気に遮られて地上までは降り注ぎ
ません
そこで私たちはロケットや人工衛星
国際宇宙ステーションに実験装置を
打ち上げてそこでこういう宇宙の極限的な
現象を観測しているわけですん
例えば私はアメリカの nasa ゴダード
中飛行センターでここにあるないさあと
呼ばれる x 線望遠鏡の掃除作りや観測
をしてきました私の専門である中性子星て
もこれで見れる天体なんですけど非常に
巨大な科学プロジェクトの一端として
そういうサイエンスのですね最先端研究を
見ていきますこの研究の面白いところは
こういった装置っていうのはどこかに売っ
ているわけではないので自分たちで手作り
で装置を作るんですねそうするといろんな
ものを図りたくなりますでも私たちの地上
ではですね宇宙回降り注いでくるガンマ線
x 線と呼ばれるエネルギーの日かいた海
光というのはなかなか届かないのでそう
いう観測対象はないのかなというふうに
思われていましたでもところがあったん
ですね
それが実は水かな
雷あ雷雲です今までこれは電波とか派志向
とか音を使って研究はされてきたんです
けど
ガンマ線が出るというのはここ20年
ぐらいの中でわかってきたことですこう
いったエネルギーの高い光を出すにはこう
いう身近な現象の中で電子が加速されて
すごく a 気が高くなったないといけ
ないということですそれはこういった雷が
雷雲が県年の粒子加速器になっていたんだ
というそういうあの秘められた秘密があっ
たんですね
私これ天文学の研究やっている傍ら大学院
生の頃に興味を持ちまして手作りの検出器
を使ってこれを解明しようとしましたこう
いう小屋を使ってですね
日本海沿岸の冬の雷雲の観測を始めました
ラウンや雷っていうのはですね皆さんあの
身近な現象なんでどこにでもあるんです
けど多くはですね大気の結構上の方で
起きるので待機でガンマ線がすぐに吸収さ
れてしまって地上で観測することはでき
ません
しかし日本の冬の雷雲っていうのは企業が
非常に低いので知事大付近までやってきて
地上で観測することができるんですね世界
的にとてもまれな場所だというふうに言わ
れています
私アメリカで5年くらい研究した後に日本
に戻ってきた時にこれまたぜひやってみ
たいなと思ったんですねその時
国からお金をもらって提案紹介てある科研
費というとに提案しましたが残念ながら
採択してもらえませんでした
そこでその当時まだよく知られていなかっ
た学術系クラウドファンディングに挑戦し
ましたこれはふるさと納税みたいなもので
市民サポーターから直接寄付金をもらって
それで科学研究をするというものです2
ヶ月の期間を区切ってその間に100万円
をもらえたら研究がスタートできるけど
そうじゃなかったはスタートできませんっ
ていうそういう条件であって
おかげさまで160万円くらいでこれを
スタートすることができますここに出して
いるのはその時のお返しの品です
この時ですねあの
実はこれ市民サポーターと一緒にこういう
科学研究やる枠組みもあるんだなっていう
ことにちょっと気づかされたんですね
これを元手にですね友人や後輩と一緒に
このみかん箱サイズの元気4月おこわ鉄
作ってですねそれを日本海沿岸にを
たくさん設置するというプログラムを始め
ました
これでどんなものが兄てきたかというと
こんなものが見えてきました僕に示して
いるのは2台の私たちの権威月がとらえた
ガンマ線の強さを示していますこれが横軸
が時間でまず一代目のこの黒い方はですね
ガンマ線量が増えますその後この赤いもの
がですね上空に雷雲が通過すると増えてき
たというこういうのが見えてきました
雷雲なんてですね三ノ丸にいっぱいあった
わけですけどあれこんなことを知らない
ままに生きてきたんですねここ10年
ぐらいの間にこういうのが新しい手練の
真実として三
これまだどうして起きるのかよくわかって
いないんですが
なにこれって思われた方のために少し仮説
を紹介しておくとこういうことを考えてい
ます
雷雲があるとしたから上昇気流で行
祝の粒が巻き上げられて雲の中で粒同士が
ぶつかるとプラスとマイナスんでも電気に
分かれる電荷分離っていうのが起きます
そうするとですね冬の発達した雷雲の中で
は3層構造になると言われていてこの下の
方にですね
プラスとマイナスの間の強い現場電気の力
の領域が生まれます
ここでもう一つ登場人物があります
それが宇宙船と呼ばれるものでこの宇宙船
はですね宇宙のはるか彼方のどこかで発生
して加速されて地球まで届いているそう
いうものです
これが地球の大気にぶつかると
目には見えないたくさんの高ネルギーの粒
になりますそれがですね皆さんの掌に目に
は見えないですけど毎秒1個ずつ飛び込ん
でいます
こういった宇宙船の粒がこの溶液に入って
くると大気中から電子をたたき出してそれ
が加速されて客さん増えてまた加速されて
最後は大気にぶつかってガンマ線という
エネルギーの高い光を地上に放射します
こうやってサーチライトのようにガンマ線
を出しながら
非常に光を出して雲が上空を通り過ぎて
いったそれを我々が検出したんだと思って
います
しかしこれ仮設でまだよく分かりません
これが本当なのかどうなのかを調べたい
そしてどんな雲でも来てるわけじゃない
ようなんですね一部の雲だけで起きている
一体どんな雲で起きているのかを知りたい
そしてもしかするとこうあって加速された
電子が雷おこしているかもしれない
こういったことを調べたいと思いました
そこで始めたのが
シチズン3 s ラインプロジェクトです
これはこれを調べるためにはガンマ線は隊
基地であっという間に吸収されてしまうの
で研究者が一箇所に入って装置を
いただければわからないんですねいろんな
場所にたくさん装置を配ってマッピング
観測をしなければいけませんそのために
学術系クラウドファンディングで
もしかしたらって思った市民サポーターと
一緒に価格するっていうのに挑戦すること
にしました
このためにですね新しく作った装置がこれ
ですこれがコンパクトガンマ線モニター子
がもっと僕らが呼んでいるこれくらいの
コンパクトな装置でこれでですね放射線を
ガンマ線を測ることができます今ちょっと
ここを開いてみますけどこれはボタン一つ
で動作させることができて周りの元ます塩
の量を測ってそして気温とか湿度とか明る
さを全部記録し gps と情報と一緒に
自動でウェブサイトにアップロードする
機能があります
これ我々のこのプロジェクト用に開発して
きた
装置ですけどこれを1個ずつ確認して
パッキングして放送したものを郵送で市民
サポーターの人に贈りますで市民
サポーターの人はベランダに置いて
いただいてこういったものを使って一緒に
関するで参加してくださった方にはこう
いうなんか参加バッジをプレゼントすると
いうものです
このプロジェクトのコンセプトには
コレクティブ power of
science 日本語で言うと競争方
サイエンスというものがありますこれには
二つの意味を込めていて一つは大型の装置
じゃなくてこういう小型の1個ずつは非力
なんだけどそれをたくさん集めることで
何か科学的な成果を出そうというそういう
概念です
んもう一つは研究者だけのコミュニティの
中でやるんじゃなくて一般の市民
サポーターの人に最先端科学にふれて
もらいながら実施するっていうそういう
意味も込めたのがこの競争型サイズです
一つ前の冬2021年度の冬はですね
だいたい60個ぐらいの子がもを金沢に
郵送して観測することができました冬に
なると金沢こういう垂れ込めた雲がきた
からやってきてこう吹き抜けていきますで
この中のどれかも雲がガンマ線出すんです
ね私たちこれをずーっと web で館し
していて自動で見つけるとですね
ツイッターでアラートを出すような
システムも作りましたこれアラートを12
月19日に出したらいいですけどみなさん
の手元にある県4月にもしくはのこれ持っ
てない方でもあなたの上空に今変な雲がい
ますそれを写真で撮ってくださいっていう
そういうプロジェクトが今動き始めました
今これを使ってですね最先端の科学研究室
前再生できるようになっ
こういうことやってると自然って不思議で
全然新しいことができてきたりするんです
ねこれは非常に所期の成果で市民
サポーターとまだ連携するちょっと前です
けど雷が起きた直後に電子の反粒子である
陽電子が見つかったというそういう成果が
出てきましたこれは2017年にイギリス
の名チャーという雑誌に出したせいかで雷
が反粒子作ったって結構いろんなところで
大騒ぎになりました
これはですね実は雷で起きるガンマ線と
いうのが地球の体験ぶつかって原子核を
壊す核反応を起こしているんだという
新しいですね雷秘密を暴いたということで
2017年度の物理分野におけるトップ
10ブレークスルーの一つにもいらん
こうやって何かを観測していると全く
新しい自然の姿に見えて会えるというのは
とても面白いことだと思います
今私たち声を拡大して
越前さん s で科学をやろうとしてい
ます科学研究をやろうとしています
これはですね私たちのラインプロジェクト
だけではなくて日本国内に複数のシチズン
3 s のプロジェクトが立ち上がろうと
していますこの写真は私の前職の京都大学
の先生やって出した時に友人たちと月1回
行っていた京都オープンさ s meet
up というそういうイベントですここに
は日本国内で自然さ遠征行っている
プレイヤーの方をお呼びしてお話しを伺っ
て交流するというもので例えば外来の
ナメクジがどこにいるかを市民サポーター
と探す
ナメクジ捜査網とか
古文献の中に地震の記録があるかを調べる
みんなで翻刻みたいなそういう面白い
プロジェクトが複数5位
これから段々とですね全てでは無いにしろ
こういう市民サポーターと連携した自然
サイエンスの新しい潮流が出てくるんじゃ
ないかなというふう
そして私のこのトークの最後に一つみな
さんに問いを投げかけてみたいと思います
7ずサイエンスというのは科学研究を推進
するためにやっているんでしょうかという
そういうことです
これ私は違うと思うんですね私は科学論文
を書くために市民サポーターを巻き込んで
シチズンサイエンスやってるんじゃないん
です
この答えの一番象徴的な写真がこれです
これは私の友人が死にて彼のアパートの
一室に作っている粒子加速器です
これは安全に注意して小型なんだけれども
本格的な施設にあるのと同じように粒子を
加速することができるものです
彼はこれをつくっているのは論文を書き
たいから職業的な研究をしたいからでは
なくて自分で気作りしたものによって自然
を理解したいっていう探究心があるんだと
いうことをました
シチズンサイエンスをやる
下記に共通するものはここにあると思い
ます
シチズンサイエンスでですねあの
科学研究を
していくということの価値の本質的な
ところには
自然を理解したい
私たちが住んでいる世界は何なのかって
いうのを
手に触れて自分の作った装置であるいは
自分の手で観測して解析してっていうそう
いう
触ることができるような行為を通してやっ
ていくっていうことが改変だ重要だと思う
シチズンサイエンスはそういう機会を提供
することになるんだと考えてい
それはいわば科学を文化にする行為だと
いうふうに思っています文化というのは
芸術とかスポーツとか音楽と同じように
それそのものに意味があって何かの為じゃ
なくて
それによって人間がすごく豊かになって
いくんだと思う
なので価格を文化にすることによってそれ
が永続性が出ればそれによって次の世代が
価格を楽しみ私たちの科学技術文明を
つくっていくコアにもなるんじゃないかな
冒頭の私の懸念のように大型科学院が離れ
ていってしまうんじゃないかと私たちの
生活から離れてしまってんじゃないかと
いう答えの一つに出演サイエンスがあるん
だと私は思ってい
科学を文化にする
そういう視点でもし身近に沈ん財布があっ
たら一緒にやってみませんか
要は聞いていただいてありがとうござい
ました
[拍手]